my friend Doug who I hired at amblin
which is Steven Spielberg's company was
at his grandmother's funeral
and he was walking back to the car with
the rabbi and the rabbi said I have a
script in my car could you please give
it to Stephen
is it easy for a great script to go
nowhere a great script a truly great
script if you have any connection to
anybody
in the entertainment industry who can
look at that and know it's a great
script
it's gonna go someplace
you're gonna get you're gonna get
recognized people will call you they'll
want to take you out for lunch or drinks
they'll want to um hire you to write for
them they'll want to
um have be in business with you in some
way a great script now if you are living
in Oshkosh and you don't know anybody
and you're not willing to submit your
scripts to contests
it could go nowhere but if you're
willing to get it out there in a way
that someone in the entertainment
industry would get eyes on it you will
go somewhere for sure
so if someone's script is not quote
unquote going anywhere is it safe to
assume it's not any good
well what I say is scripts need to be
blazing hot
my first boss said
that writing is choices
and when you have a character who has to
make a choice
the First Choice you come up with
anybody could come up with my dentist
would come up with the second choice
pretty obvious the third choice a little
bit less and then
four five and six if you can push
yourself to there it's getting better
if you're at
8 9 and 10 and not many people are ten
that you've forced yourself to try 10
different choices until you get to the
very best choice
then that script is good
but if you're if you're at four or five
and you try four or five things and you
said no this this is this is good enough
then
if it's been out there in the
marketplace for three or four or five
months it's not the marketplace it's
your script it's not ready and I
encourage you to either rewrite it or
write something else because every time
you write a new script
it's gonna get better
so it's not them it's me yes okay and
what we talked about earlier was that
when you meet a Storyteller you can kind
of tell that you know they see the world
in a very different way they're very
dialed in to little details and is that
where the the real beauty of a
Storyteller takes over is that that
taking it Beyond level four in terms of
how you know little nuances to the to
the script yes I think so great
storytellers are at 789
brilliant you know Aaron Sorkin 10 right
but the rest of us humans you know
regular people it's not fair yeah seven
eight nine you know that if you're
willing to bleed for it to get to seven
eight or nine
then I think you're probably a really
good storyteller what are the best ways
for a new Rider to get industry Pros to
read their script really good question
if you don't know anybody
there are first of all beware be really
wary of
coverage Services they're not all made
equally you need to know who's reading
your script it could be a junior
executive it could be a bartender
and what I tell people is if you are
getting coverage
um
only listen to what resonates and if you
re and be really honest with yourself is
that a good note is that a note from
somebody who doesn't get what I'm doing
at all
so one way is contests
um you don't have to know anybody to
enter your scripts into contests and if
you come in first second or third in a
prestigious contest agents managers
producers will find you if you don't do
that there are services but always check
and see who is behind the service what
their real credits are and if they've
been doing something if they were a
reader for six months that's not who you
want
okay so having never entered a contest
would they say who some of the industry
professionals are or they say have
worked with but you don't actually know
the person's name can't check their
credits
you mean in a contest or coverage
service right if they're not telling you
then don't go there right yeah I'm
always wary of websites whatever
industry where you don't know the family
name or the person behind it even if
there's no picture but just to have a
general sense of who someone is behind
it that you're giving your money to if
they're not willing to tell you who they
are they don't have to necessarily give
you a last name better if they do but
what that person's credentials are if
they're not willing to do that
specifically don't spend your money
there
okay so what if a new writer has
identified maybe five contests that are
definitely legit they see it on
screenwriting Twitter people are
discussing it should they continue to
enter them even if they haven't won and
they haven't gotten any favorable notes
back
yes continue to write and get better at
writing I've known people
from icbs program that have applied four
times and it wasn't until the fifth time
that they got in because it wasn't until
the fifth year that their material was
good enough but if year after year after
year you're not getting any traction
then there's then you're missing
something and maybe you should take a
class maybe you should do an online
course but again only reputable ones
don't waste your money on I always like
to say in terms of contests
coming in third place in the schmagi
film festival is going to do nothing for
you
um
yeah push yourself to that seven eight
or nine sure sure yeah you can you can
check in on what screenwriters are doing
on on Reddit on LinkedIn
um on Twitter and so you know you see
people who are very proud that they've
placed and and to to follow suit I guess
yeah
um fortune favors the Bold absolutely
why do you love this uh is this a saying
or a proverb yes it's a proverb and do I
remember who said it no but it is a
famous saying
this if you're not willing to take a
risk sell insurance
if you're willing to take a risk if
you're willing to boldly say this is my
vision I stand behind it I'm putting in
my 10 000 hours I'm gonna get better I
have a story to tell and I'm willing to
do whatever it takes to tell it
then interestingly the universe comes
along and gives you a push that's what I
think
okay I like that uh what if there are
responsibilities you know you talked
about a woman that you're working with
who who had a child to raise and
understandably had to put things on the
back burner for a while
um how does someone navigate that I I
don't know I guess it's specific for
each situation I think so but you don't
have a number of clients in that
situation and we come up with a plan for
how they can get time in even if it's a
little time
on a daily basis I 30 minutes a day and
I know some writers that get up 30
minutes early before their kids get up I
know some writers that stay up 30
minutes later if their brain is still
working
if you do that and I say only work four
days a week I really believe you need to
have a life and
in order to write about something you
need creativity in to have creativity
out and
just carve some time for yourself I know
it's really hard I don't mean to be flip
about it but
30 minutes even if it's 15 minutes a day
you will find yourself making progress
okay what if someone is lucky enough to
have that time but they feel selfish we
talked to another uh both writer and Mom
and that there is a connotation
sometimes that it's selfish
that what I'm doing is is you know why
why am I doing this I should be taking
care of someone else
codependent
um read Melody Beatty right read Melody
Beauty for that codependence okay
you have to find the strength inside
yourself
that says I deserve this I don't mean
leave your children in the street but
carve out 30 minutes you have to find
inside yourself the essential you that
yearns to be an artist and say I'm going
to devote some of my time and energy on
a regular basis to that I just saw the
documentary Judy Bloom forever and
she had to ultimately I'm not suggesting
this but she had to ultimately leave her
husband because he didn't want her to
pursue her craft don't leave your
husband don't leave your wife I'm not
saying that sure I'm saying it's good to
surround yourself with people that
support you in your in your desire
oh I want to see that movie I did not I
love Judy Bloom so it was a documentary
actually okay right yeah and that just
came out just came out wow because now
her her are you there God it's me
Margaret yeah it came out good times I
do will well you know that's a that's a
tough uh comedic uh it is you know not
everyone's going to get some of the
humor there yeah things like that but um
that was that's a landmark book for it
and many many people he is and was and
is still is yeah yeah and has been
banned
so but I I wanna I wanna see that
documentary that's good I like that what
is the general timeline for getting a
screenplay read if you're a new writer
and you're sending it out to
professionals
yep okay
here's what I say first of all
I have a pet peeve that I want to share
with the people who are watching this do
not ask somebody you've just met to read
your script
it I did a Blog about Hollywood
etiquette don't do that because I just
want people to think about this
you're asking me a person
that you don't know and I don't know you
to take two hours out of my life away
from my family and my work to read your
script
wait until you know somebody so please
please please don't say nice to meet you
will you read my script
but let's say you have been able to put
it in the hands of somebody who is in
the industry what I say is give people
six weeks to start
and then reach out to them
every month after that every three or
four weeks and always be respectful and
say I know how busy you are I just
wanted to Circle back and see if you've
had an opportunity to read it and if not
no worries I'll check back in again in
another month
I know somebody who gave it to a
showrunner
and it took that showrunner a year to
read it but she finally did and she gave
her feedback but if you've been reaching
out to people and don't annoy them just
do it regularly but not annoyingly and
if they haven't responded to you in a
year
stop reaching out and find somebody else
what about if someone sends it to
someone or or email someone and says I
know you know so and so fill in the
blank can you get it to that person now
you're asking that person to risk that
relationship their reputation protocol
yeah
that is the same thing as asking
somebody to read your script you ask me
to give it to
I have a funny story if you want to hear
it I do yeah okay my friend Doug who I
hired at amblin which is Steven
Spielberg's company was at his
grandmother's funeral
and he was walking back to the car with
the rabbi and the rabbi said I have a
script in my car could you please give
it to Stephen oh don't do that
don't do that okay
um you're asking me
if you say well you get it to so and so
I don't know you to use up one of my
chits to you to to use up one of my
credibility chits
don't do that you're asking too much
now if I meet you and we have a
relationship and I really like you I'll
ask you to read your script let me read
your script and if the script is
fabulous I will pass it along don't ask
me to pass it along but if I love it let
me tell you I'm going to pass it along
because it makes me look good I
discovered this person
but you don't ask you let it happen
well what ended up happening in that
situation or is that too personal
no she got wrapped
with the the person whose Rabbi asked oh
nothing happened
nothing happened right because Doug
would no more take that person's script
and give it to Stephen his boss
then he would walk on the moon what
happened is that Doug would not hire
that Rabbi to do his grandfather's
funeral